bom dia a todos bom dia a todos
cuba já deu errado aqui é nós vamos
falar sobre a inconstitucionalidade da
criminalização do aborto e sempre que
nós falamos de aborto é preciso que seja
lembrado imediatamente sempre que o
brasil em 1994 subscrever um tratado
internacional de direitos humanos
afirmando que os estados não devem
promover o aborto como método
anticonceptivo mas reconhecem que o
aborto é um problema de saúde pública e
logo em seguida em 1995 o brasil também
ratificou um outro compromisso
internacional comprometendo se a rever a
realizar a sua legislação punitiva
repressiva com relação ao aborto e o
brasil não tem cumprido esse acordo
internacional esse compromisso
internacional e continua criminalizando
o aborto prevendo a porto covo uma
conduta criminosa
o artigo 124 ao auto aborto também
criminaliza o aborto com o consentimento
da gestante e inclusive pois bem mais de
embu se sagre democrático o legislador
quando cria uma conduta criminosa quando
quem analisa uma conduta ele tem de
submeter a alguns princípios
democráticos alguns princípios que
limitam a criminalização de condutas e
esses princípios como eu vou mostrar que
estão sendo violados pela legislação
brasileira
nós vamos falar sobre princípio da
unidade da subsidiariedade e da
racionalidade a outros princípios mas o
gol minha terra esses três
pois bem o que é o princípio da
idoneidade princípio funcional a
criminalização de qualquer computador
deve ser um meio útil e eficaz
antónio para controlar um determinado
problema social ou seja precisa ser
muito para resolver o problema que se
propõe a resolver o que acontece no
brasil com relação ao acordo apesar da
sua criminalização e desde 1940
no brasil são praticados por ano de 700
mil a 1 milhão de apartamentos organon a
cada 30 entre mulheres brasileiras já
praticaram o abortamento
enfim nós poderíamos aqui citar muitos
no mundo dos outros dados para
demonstrar que a criminalização do
acordo é ineficaz não está auxiliando em
nada não está colaborando em nada para
evitar a prática do abortamento tocando
viola o princípio da impunidade
vamos o princípio da racionalidade no
processo democrático de imunização devem
ser considerados os benefícios e os
custos sociais aos autos pela adoção da
medida protecionista proibicionista e
metralhadora ou seja que pode
criminalizar uma onda precisa verificar
se ela não tá causando um mal pior do
que aquele problema que ela tem que
enfrentar o que nós vemos no brasil quem
a criminalização do acordo é a principal
responsável pelo aborto inseguro
então nós temos no brasil hoje a um
aborto praticado na clandestinidade e
condições péssimas sanitárias e as
mulheres morrem o aborto inseguro mata
as mulheres são 20 por cento de mortes
maternas maranhão salvador a primeira
causa de morte materna em são paulo a
terceira causa de morte materna aliás o
acordo inseguras e quinta causa mais
freqüente de internação nos hospitais
brasileiros nem um segundo procedimento
obstétrico no brasil
enfim se o mundo morrem 60 70 mil
mulheres por ano por acordo e seguro no
brasil a morte de mulheres por
abortamento em segundo é a segunda ou
terceira causa de morte materna além da
morte as mulheres que sobrevivem ao
aborto inseguro sofrem seqüelas
terríveis físicas psíquicas
além das conseqüências sociais e
econômicas geralmente são as mulheres
que suportam em sua maior intensidade
portanto esse a criminalização do acordo
viola flagrantemente o princípio da
racionalidade
mas há também o princípio da
subsidiariedade a criminalização somente
se justifica quando não houver outros
meios ou outras alternativas para o
enfrentamento do problema social a ser a
gostar ou seja a opção pela
criminalização do do abortamento não só
o comportamento de comer com dotar a
opção pela conduta de criminalizar o
estado tem que ser sempre a última
alternativa à ultima rácio a última
solução porque a solução é essa a
solução criminalizadora e muito
virulenta
então ela tem que ser deixado para o
último caso e nós temos que dar
garantias a outras alternativas para o
enfrentamento da questão desse problema
social que o abortamento evidente que
sim existem políticas públicas que podem
ser adotadas não é para a efetivação de
programas eficientes de planejamento
familiar educação formal informal
capacidade de profissionais para
promover o acolhimento às mulheres
mantença de estruturas sanitárias
preparadas para garantir os direitos à
saúde física e psicológica a mantença do
sistema de acolhimento orientação
especialmente sobretudo o empoderamento
das mulheres no âmbito social o político
principalmente e coloque com essas
medidas poderiam ser muito mais eficazes
e efetivas do que a própria
criminalização que é extremamente
agressiva enganosa
nós precisamos lembrar então do que
dizia carlos drumond de andrade né
as leis não bastam os lírios não nascem
das leis não serão as leis as
responsáveis pelas soluções dos
problemas mas sim de políticas públicas
principalmente mas há a criminalização
do aborto então viola o princípio da
subsidiariedade e eu não poderia deixar
de lembrar também que além de dólares
três princípios constitucionais
a criminalização do aborto também viola
princípios jurídicos jurídico penais
por exemplo o legislador não pode não
deve criminalizar uma completa de modo
simbólico e é o que acontece com o
abortamento o o jogador não deve
criminalizar uma conduta para entoru uma
determinada concepção moral e é o que
acontece com a penalização do aborto
não se deve criminalizar condutas
freqüentemente aceitas e praticadas por
parte significativa da população e é
também o que acontece com a finalização
do acordo
pois bem a mas não é só eu gostaria de
acrescentar ainda ea criminalização do
acordo viola também inclusive seres nos
princípios de direitos humanos também
como diz a juíza flávia piovesan é uma
das maiores especialistas humano e
direitos humanos os direitos sexuais e
reprodutivos devem ser compreendidos sob
a perspectiva dos direitos humanos e
missô e é sob esse prisma que se insere
a problemática do aborto problemática do
aborto é uma problemática de direitos
humanos e o sistema de proteção
internacional dos direitos humanos têm
afirmado reiteradamente às vezes em
várias conferências em vários documentos
e à criminalização do aborto é
absolutamente incompatível com a
garantia dos direitos humanos das
mulheres especialmente com a garantia
dos direitos humanos sexuais e
reprodutivos das mulheres seu direito à
assistência à saúde
o sistema internacional direitos humanos
têm afirmado vai a vez de os estados
devem promover a descriminalização do
aborto por causa disso a criminalização
do aborto em face de seu caráter
repressivo exclui esquematiza e bed que
as mulheres seja garantido o direito à
sobre seu direito à assistência
sanitária mais o sistema de proteção dos
direitos humanos garante também as
mulheres
o controle o direito de controle a sua
sexualidade
o direito à livre decisão sem conversão
discriminação ou violência um direito
fundamental o direito de decidir sobre o
exercício da maternidade e um direito à
auto-determinação no âmbito da sua
sexualidade todos esses direitos são
violados exatamente com a criminalização
do aborto e isso me faz lembrar essa
frase do chico buarque de holanda com
glória as mulheres nessa situação ea sua
autonomia violada né
a gente quer ter voz ativa no nosso
destino mandar pois bem mas isso é
importante que se diga o sistema de
proteção de direitos humanos tenha
afirmado também reiteraram as vezes que
a descriminalização do aborto não viola
o direito à vida como se tem afirmado
infelizmente ignorando essas decisões
por exemplo já foram tomadas como as
cortes pelas comissões internacionais
direitos humanos à comissão
interamericana de direitos humanos
afirmou isso expressamente que a
jurisprudência afirma que o acordo não
viola o direito à visita à corte
européia de direitos humanos enfrentou
essa questão e também afirmou decidiu
expressamente que os estados têm
discricionalidade legítima para permitir
o acompanhamento ea corte constitucional
portuguesa recentemente enfrentando a
questão essa questão quando foi
descriminalizado o aborto até a 12ª
semana
nessa primeira semana em portugal
afirmou exatamente isso que a vida
intra-uterina reclama proteção do estado
mas a constituição portuguesa exatamente
como a brasileira não obriga que essa
proteção à natureza penal
não sendo possível concluir que a
ausência de proteção penal equivale pura
e simplesmente outro exemplo é a
proteção
nós estamos falando portanto apenas em
descriminalização
portanto nós podemos concluir o seguinte
que a criminalização do aborto
winona princípios constitucionais viola
princípios jurídicos penais é
incompatível com o sistema de proteção
dos direitos humanos sexuais e
reprodutivos das mulheres não tem sido
eficaz nenhum
para proteção da vida em a uti na
acarreta as mulheres terríveis sequelas
engorde está sendo mantida com um enorme
custo social e beth a implantação de
medidas eficazes para o enfrentamento
desse problema de saúde pública mas
sobretudo embasada nos paradigmas da
ideologia patriarcal de dominação
masculina a criminalização do aborto
constituem um instrumento ideológico de
controle na sexualidade de lina
portanto acredito que chegou o momento
os legisladores brasileiros da nação
brasileira ouvir o que pela pessoa tem a
dizer sobre isso
nós precisamos descriminalizar o acordo
sim imediatamente porque há um tempo em
que é preciso abandonar as roupas usadas
que já têm a forma do nosso corpo e
esquecer os nossos caminhos que nos
levam sempre aos mesmos lugares
é o tempo de travessia e se não ousarmos
fazê-la teremos ficado para sempre à
margem de nós mesmos
obrigado